hello everyone and welcome back to some
daily rapid action unleashes We are
continuing our streak hopefully we've
won the last two games and we are going
to play another one uh yesterday we
blundered a piece in the opening but we
were able to win somehow hopefully today
we don't um blunder anything and still
win but you know even if we don't
hopefully uh hopefully we won't blunder
uh badly uh so let's check it out we get
the white pieces and our opponent is
Andre Andre d from
Russia uh at 2294 so let's open up with
our standard stuff point to E4 and uh
well okay so he goes for the Sicilian
Defense we will not have the Revenge of
the Evans today uh but we might try it
uh we might still try it yeah we might
still try it yeah uh we're going to go
Pawn to B4 here uh we played a nice one
I think we already played a nice one in
uh this line it's the only line of the
Sicilian where I employ B4 simply
because it's uh very strong and yeah he
plays uh Pawn to E6 usually D5 is
considered the the main move against the
this but this is sort of the this is
sort of to trick you because if you go
D5 right away then Queen to F6 uh could
be very annoying uh as it will uh put
put pressure on your Rook so we're going
to play uh Bishop to B2 first and now
prepare this
move yeah okay so now he plays it uh
we're going to play captures captures
and oh so now now he can even capture
with the pawn yeah so it's a it's a bit
different uh yeah we'll have to check
how that uh how that uh is different but
yeah we can still go just Bishop to
B5 uh we're going to Castle next we
don't have to worry about the check
because we can block it with Knight C3
and defend our Bishop so let's just
Castle the
safety yeah not nothing special but
still it's uh it's okay all right so how
do we how do we get at least something
all right let's get our Knight here uh
threatened to win material back and if
plays Bishop okay so he goes Queen to B6
uh which uh made possible because the
bishop here is
undefended uh okay now it's time to now
it's time to really start
thinking
oh yeah the bishop here is definitely
very
nice yeah Bishop tob2 I'm I'm starting
to think that Bishop tob2 isn't really
precise here here uh because if I play
such a forcing line I should really
learn how to play it properly if uh if
my opponent doesn't go for the main line
of this tricky stuff cuz I'm the one
that's supposed to be surprising him and
I'm the one wasting
time uh yeah this is uh very very
annoying but what are you going to do
that's that's chess all right so we're
just going to develop nothing special
here Knight to Knight to C3 we're going
to defend our Bishop and if he goes A6
okay we're going to capture and defend
then but here he's probably going to
Castle let's go Rook
B1 uh yeah we didn't get all yeah so he
will capture yeah I was wondering about
that is that even
possible it looks uh it looks that it
shouldn't be possible but he says it's
possible he let go Knight
D5 if he can be tricked we can be tricky
because now if he goes here the E7
Bishop hangs if he doesn't if he goes
here then we just oh he's going to
capture
here that that's wise that's very
wise H let's go
here okay so he's not afraid of any
nasty discoveries here I like that I
like that that he isn't afraid of nasty
discoveries do we have any nasty
discoveries of our own like Knight
captures on F7 maybe and then Rook
captur maybe some Bishop E8 stuff no
that's that's too that's too crazy even
for me yeah let's not try
that uh but we could go
for oh that looks that looks so
disgusting
h
how does he stop Knight
C4 how does he defend the bishop that's
the
question he's probably just going to
play Bishop captures on D4 and give up
his
Queen unless he has Knight
C3 that is also a very nice no but he
doesn't yeah he
doesn't cuz I can just okay so he's
going to okay so Queen C7 yeah I'm blind
here sort of blind
here yeah but now it's it's uh now we
can just play captures
here yeah this is turning into a very
ugly game very ugly game indeed so it's
not even a game this is this is a slug
Fest yeah this is not something you
should uh
now he's going to play Bishop D6 I'm
going to have to be careful where to
move my queen because he has Bishop
captures and then if I capture Bishop
captures and F2 check where he might
pick this up something something yeah
it's equal material but
uh if I can if I can mobilize my pieces
I should be a little bit better due to
his exposed King he does have the bishop
pair if he can maybe position them
nicely of course it it could be very
dangerous I don't know I feel like we've
B uh we've both uh done things we
shouldn't have this game okay so he goes
uh yeah that's very nice that's very
nice
indeed how do we how do we deal with
this of course if we if we just
move then he's going to play B5 attack
uh both of our pieces yeah
not the
best yeah he does have that that's very
annoying let's go here I mean we we do
have a draw if we want it we could we we
always have a
Perpetual so I will have to think very
hard whether to take it or
not
[Music]
um do we have something like Queen F6
check King G8 Rook B3 maybe going for
for checkmate or maybe winning on the
spot yeah he'll always be able to to
defend with the bishop but no this is
actually perfectly
fine yeah born out of
necessity how does he defend Rook B3
this is does not work both Knight and
Bishop cover that if I play this he will
play Bishop
G4 yeah but that's also pointless if I
defend like yeah I mean nothing nothing
really works
here
huh
okay I still have four minutes so I
might as well check maybe maybe I have
something better other than Rook B3 but
I don't think I
do and I don't see a way for him to
actually stop that yeah he could play
Bishop
F5 sort of I cannot play this because
then he can block he will I will I will
have to take yeah but he still can't uh
take the bishop due to Queen F6 I'm just
going to play Queen back to F6 so but
yeah okay so this is possible Rook B3
Bishop F5 I take he plays
F6 yeah that's
possible but yeah I don't see a better
move out than Rook to B3 so I might as
well go for
it Ah that's actually very
tricky that's actually very
tricky
uh one move that I haven't
checked and it's because uh if I play
Rook now he will just take it with the
queen yeah it's very very
interesting but
Still Still Still
Still
yeah
Queen
H6 and I don't see it I don't see a
defense yeah he will he will now of
course uh take after I take here so I
might as well okay so he also frees up
the A3 squar that's very
interesting very interesting
indeed
yeah he managed to to make it
complicated I'm down to two minutes yeah
he's he's finding
resources yeah since he can
uh yeah there's no way there's no other
way to do
it yeah if I just move the Knight he'll
play Rook
A3 Rook A3 and then um I've lost all of
my
uh all of my ability to
bargain yeah but I I can play Knight the
No No I can't I can't really really I
can't yeah it has to be done it has to
be done no but I can play this yeah uh
much better to have the Rook on A5 then
to UND double his pawns if I already
have to give up the
Knight wow so much time wasted he's
probably he's probably like what is this
silly move and now he's probably going
to play something like yeah now he can
actually play Bishop to F5 I'm so
silly yeah I'm so silly this is this is
so
bad
yeah no I over complicated it even for
myself no he will not do it okay
so he will do it this
way all right let's open up
our I kind of feel like I have to
capture with the H Pawn even though I
kind of want to get my Rook into the
game but
yeah uh H Pawn capture is what you
should do most of the time so now yeah
so now he definitely has compensation
for the queen but I have to I have to
start
pushing yeah he will play Rook captures
no doubt
there now he has some captures Bishop
here
ideas uh looks way worse than I I
imagined it in my head probably it is it
possible it was never even better for me
H it's possible of course he found some
beautiful
ideas yeah the bishop has access to f8
so it's not
really not really a problem he he's not
going to get checkmated but uh he might
have to play Bishop to f8 right away
yeah if he just moves the bishop then I
have again no he he's not going to do it
okay
um so now we're going to play Rook
C1 Rook C1 with the simple idea of uh
Rook captures on
C5 and even though he has all of this
material oh yeah he doesn't have a check
and he doesn't have a check any other
way so it's maybe still possible to
Checkmate him I don't know we'll see
yeah okay so he stops Rook captures uh
as he
should now we have to go for check we
don't have any
other we don't have any other
moves yeah do we have to now I I feel
like I have to settle for a
perpetual
is there anything yeah I don't think
there is yeah he's probably not going to
even allow it now yeah because I have 14
seconds on the clock he doesn't
care but that might cost him it might
cost me the game but it might also cost
him the
game we'll
see can always just play Bishop D D6
yeah and uh defend
everything so yeah not at the moment
because the bishop here will hang uh but
uh yeah let's try to get him let's try
to get him over
there going to play this maybe to
threaten my Pawn here yeah which is very
nice of
course yeah pin the bishop I don't care
about a
check can give one check 8 seconds on
the clock
carry
stuff if he goes there I'm going to
capture the bishop what can I do with
eight seconds not a lot he has five
minutes if he checks me I go up if he
moves I take the
bishop yeah no way to to win this with 8
seconds but we'll do our
best yeah looking forward to analyzing
this after the
game uh should have uh yeah that's the
problem now he can think all he wants
and I always have to be ready to make
like the the pre
move which I don't think it's possible
to win even if he just uh Flags me he
he's still going to win so it's not
really a even a question yeah he's going
to play that okay so now we have to
take okay so he does that even wow okay
now he's
lost now he's lost if I can win
it
okay this is I have
to tap into my Spidey Sense to win
this okay so he wants to give checks of
course there we go we're going to take
that take this as well push the
pawn check here bring a Queen into the
game and hide our
king that's what we're going to do there
we go there we go there we go take the
queen or go
here go here go here it's a B
Pawn all right I don't think I have the
time to do
this no I don't have
time all right so uh it was okay we we
managed to get a draw here uh even
though the position
in the end is winning uh there's a uh
yeah if it was like a like an a pawn or
a c pawn it would be a draw but if it's
a B Pawn it's a win uh simply because
after I check he goes here and then I
get to bring my king into the game but
with one second on the clock uh I
couldn't uh I couldn't do it I know I
know some people who could do it I'm not
one of them uh but yeah uh let's let's
just see uh I will have to improve on
this E6 line though yeah Bishop to be 3
already Bishop to B2 already
suboptimal so not the best okay but this
is still 0.5 this is all drawish
territory uh just fun to play but yeah
Rook B1 not spectacular it was better to
capture here so I'm really just
surviving here yeah he messed up with
this capture because he allows me back
into the game but still it's um uh as
you can see on the on the little engine
bar there it's
0.1 so nothing here Bishop C5 yeah he
blundered with Bishop to C5 but I I
missed the killer with Bishop to C4 I
actually played Knight to C4 which is
okay but it's still draw yeah Bishop C4
attacks the queen and puts pressure on
the Knight and then after he defends the
Knight what's the what's the the okay so
he cannot defend both and if he plays
this then it's okay then it's just
captures yeah I mean yeah that's a
pretty big Miss by me uh but it's you
know with an open open board and so many
pieces in the middle yeah I play Bishop
captures this is fine this is fine he
played A6 Queen G5 check and now okay
probably we should go for a
draw Bishop A4
why why Bishop
A4 Bishop what B5 doesn't work okay so
yeah Rook e one and now if he
takes now it's still a draw uh yeah we
get to repeat so that's the objective
evaluation of the
position uh but we did not go for that
we uh went for Rook B3 Bishop B7 Queen
oh not Queen H6 Queen B6 yeah okay I
overplayed my hand here a little bit
Knight A5 yeah and now yeah now he even
had Rook A6 yeah it's also something
that I missed Rook B5 check but why not
after Knight A5 why not Bishop to G4
what was wrong with
that I still play Rook G3 three and now
F5 and now H3 okay but I thought he sort
of escapes here
no uh yeah I mean that was uh that was
definitely the way to go for him but
yeah we both really over complicated
this yeah and now I played this and he
with this Rook to C8 move he allowed me
into the game F5 yeah here okay uh he
stopped Rook captures on
C5 uh and now I had to accept a draw but
he didn't want to draw he wanted to flag
me and I played F6 which is objectively
losing but now it's uh yeah now we're
just uh playing moves Rook captures yeah
he's completely winning now but now with
Rook G1 now I'm completely
winning uh with all of these checks you
now if I if I had more time on the clock
I was already down to 3 seconds here uh
I could win but no it was uh it was not
possible uh but yeah not uh not the the
most precise game but um uh it was it
was a lot of fun playing B4 against the
Knight to C6 Sicilian against a a high
rated opponent 2294 that's not bad and
um yeah I will I will have to improve on
that line and not a lot of people play
it most people if you guys just want to
uh see how it usually goes here D5 is
strongest recommended by the engine and
after he captures Queen captures you go
Knight C3 now everything except Queen to
A5 is losing for black he he goes back
he's just dead lost he go has to go here
you're going to block with Bishop to D2
and now they're going to play E6 which
is the strongest by the engine and
everyone plays this I I play this in
like three minute blades and they want
to go Bishop to B4 you're going to play
Rook B1 and after Bishop to B4 you're
going to capture that Bishop that's the
point and uh this is
0.0 H but very very fun to play Pawn to
D5 and I after captures captures the
queen is attacked twice you will
delivers a check here and now okay it's
being played but black has to be uh very
very careful here like how do you
develop you go knight2 F6 uh Knight to
C7 check and already black has problems
so it's a very very tricky position he
has to play King f8 and then he has to
figure out how to get his pieces into
the game uh for for a three minute Blitz
game or a five minute Blitz game I would
even play it in Rapid you know it's uh
perfectly perfectly playable uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
sorry sorry for coming short this one uh
but you know could have been a lot worse
as you've seen in the previous video I
was down a piece and I I was able to get
back into it but uh yeah here was um I
mean what are you going to do uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh see you in the next
one